- Most celebrities have a talent,
like singing, dancing, acting,
but I don't really know
what the Kardashians do.
- I know that people think that
the Kardashians are stupid,
but I don't know how anybody
with that much money could be stupid.
- I don't know why they're rich.
- Their late father was a lawyer
who represented OJ Simpson?
- Okay, that's the mom.
She's a good looking lady.
- The mom's friend went to a party
where the party favors were Viagra?
- It's nice to see older women talking
about sex on television.
- Yeah, this family seems
really, really weird.
- I think Scott might be a psychopath,
but he seems like the only one
that has any idea what's going on.
- And honestly the only one that seems
at all normal is Bruce.
- Is it bad if I like Scott?
- The mom is drugging
Bruce Jenner with Viagra.
- Why is Kris forcing
Bruce to do something
that he clearly doesn't want to do?
- Now she made another
drugged coffee for the husband
but, but Rob, her son took it.
- Did Rob accidentally
take the pill coffee?
- Her son is gonna have
like four days of boners.
- So he got an erection from his mom,
which seems very weird.
- This is like a classic sitcom.
All of these plots were
taken from Three's Company.
- This is just the worst
scripted show in the world.
This isn't reality.
- So from what I can tell, the Kardashians
are very irritating people but also,
I kind of can't look away.
- This is good fodder for nights
when you just want the TV on
and you don't actually want to
pay attention to what you're watching.
- I know that that
interview that just came out
with Bruce Jenner was incredibly moving
and incredibly brave
and then all the others
came out and Kris showed support
and Kim showed support, so really,
it's just a family show with Viagra.
- Not enough Kim.
Where's Kim?
What is she doing?
- I like how it's only
now that Kris Jenner
is like, "I think it might be
"the coffee."